Speaker 1: Let's hear from people in the
audience. It's a novel concept. I know,
but let's hear from people in the audience. We
do this via discord. You can find the discord
at David Pakman dot com slash discord
conveniently enough. Let's start today
with Tom from New Jersey. Tom, you
were on the air. What's on your mind?
Speaker 2: Hey, David, can you hear me? I can.
Hey, this is my first time calling. I've been
listening to you since twenty sixteen, so
thank you. Yeah, I just started a new semester,
which is my first time in person in a classroom in
two years. Yep. Yep. Yesterday I had a professor
tell us about for an hour why she was
a vaccine, hesitant and she was talking
about how the CDC said people who had cold
it shouldn't get the vaccine. My question is
like, what should we do about like people who
are professionals, who are telling students and
such they shouldn't get the vaccine beautiful.
Speaker 1: So first of all, what she is saying is
untrue. The the CDC has not told people who have
been sick with covid not to get the vaccine. I
do believe there at one point was a requirement
that you wait some number of days after recovering
before getting the vaccine. But I am not aware of
anything about if you've if you've been if you've
had covered, don't get vaccinated. That's number
one. Number two, what what type of class is this?
What's the subject matter of the class?
Speaker 2: You'll never believe. But
it's a health psychology class.
Speaker 1: OK, so it is not a class
on epidemiology and it doesn't seem like the woman
or virology. It doesn't seem that the professors
of views on vaccination are relevant. So what I
would do is I would go to the department chair,
I would go to the provost, I would let everybody
know. Director, is is this an undergraduate class?
Yeah, director of undergraduate studies, whatever,
I would let everybody know I am filing a complaint
because the teacher in a health psychology class
spent an hour ranting about her vaccine hesitancy,
including spreading, you know, incorrect
statements contradictory to the CDC. I would
just report it and let the university handle it.
Speaker 2: All right. Thanks, Pakman. I was
incredibly frustrated yesterday listening to that.
Speaker 1: It's horrible. It's absolutely crazy.
And it's I mean, listen, it's probably happening
at a lot of different places is the reality. Yeah.
Yeah. You think you'll do it? You'll report it.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I'm planning to.
Speaker 1: OK, good. Please follow.
Let us know what happens. OK.
All right. Thank you. I'll call back. Thank you
Tom from New Jersey. Yeah. Let's get that going.
We've got to deal with that. That just can't be
allowed. It's it's a real it's a real problem.
All right. Let's go next to let's go to Miguel
from El Paso, Texas. Miguel, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: I can you hear me? Yes, I can.
OK, perfect. Hi, David. So I had a question,
I have two questions. In fact, I wanted to know
whether you'd be interested in in interviewing
someone from or reaching out to the sunrise
movement. Do you know about the Sunrise movement?
Speaker 1: I'm familiar with the I
remember the name of the organization.
Are they sort of a like releasing public
records and documents about things type group?
Speaker 2: Not really, they're a they're like an
organized movement made up of young individuals
like me who are trying to who do activism
for mostly environmental causes. So they have
plenty of chapters all around the United States.
And their main goal is to spread like the basis
of the Green New Deal to, you know, not just
in the national white sense, but also like in
local in your local chapters, see what they got
to bring a green new deal, proposals to to local
Speaker 1: level, to local areas that it sounds
like great work as an interview on the show.
It would be what we call a dud. Unfortunately,
those types of interviews don't do well. They'll
get 2000 views and people will write to me
and say, David, that was that really was was
not a good interview for the show. So I love what
you're describing that the organization is doing.
I'm not going to, you know, kind of
blow smoke, though. It's probably not
an interview for this particular show.
Speaker 2: That's OK, I understand. I
just I was just thinking, like, you know, there's
plenty of people out there, young people like me,
who don't want to do something about
climate change. Yeah. And they don't
know exactly where to go. And, you know, maybe
an interview with a representative or someone
of that reporter could bring light to that.
Maybe they can go somewhere that, you know,
they can make some change. But that's OK.
I understand fully, if it's your show, you
do what's best for you. Good. My second question
is not as serious. So given that you're a native
from Argentina, am I correct in that assessment?
Speaker 1: That's an absolutely
correct assessment. Yeah.
Speaker 2: Perfect. So I wanted to know
what your opinion is on a famous popular band so
that Stadio love I love them. Yeah. Do you have a
do you have a favorite record that
you would recommend as a beginner or.
Speaker 1: No, no, I don't I'm not familiar enough
with the discography to be able to recommend
specific records. But no, right before the
pandemic, I went to a soda stereo cover band
and I know no great, great band
of many great Argentinean bands.
Speaker 2: All right, perfect. I was just
curious about that. Thank you so much,
David. I really appreciate it.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you
very much. Appreciate the call. Very
nice guy. Great to hear from people